des [ __ ] alors que mine de rien
derrière eh ben mine de rien ça fait ça
fait manger des millions de personnes on
a besoin d'eux et que tous ces artistes
font ça bénévolement et il se prête au
spectacle vous voulez vous montrer des
extraits après vous pouvez juger l'objet
télévisuel mais ce qu'on peut même
critiqué l' objet télévisuel des
[ __ ] on a voulu commencer par vous
montrer l'ouverture du concert des
[ __ ] voit la fin je lui c'était
c'était assez joli vous avez déjà fait
des emplois ou pas non on m'a demandé
plusieurs fois mais je chaque fois je
suis pas libre vous le feriez sinon bien
sûr bien sûr oui
non mais l'année dernière j'avais un
problème c'est que je pouvais en faire
que trois le que 3 et le dont celui qui
était diffusée pour la télévision mais
comme c'était la première fois j'avais
envie d'un peut-être un petit peu avec
l'équipe rennes avant pour me mettre
dans le chanteur revient donc c'est
impressionnant quand même hyper bien oui
si si si je ce qu'il faut c'est ce m en
comme le font beaucoup d'entre eux et
c'est ce qui est louable
c'est que il se libère pour justement
avant dans leur tournée pour être bien
précis ce qui l'aurait bien que je fasse
avant